hey the 12th be with you thank you how
are you how is Quarantine life treating
you what is your day looking like well
it's so surreal I've never forgotten
what day of the week it is more often
than since we've been shut down on but
you know I'm sort of reclusive anyway so
part of me can appreciate it but I can
understand people are just going
stir-crazy yeah well you do you know you
do a lot of voice work and you're one of
my favorites you're my favorite Joker um
are you able to work from home or how is
that working well I'm working for mom
right now speaking with you we are
zooming yeah so far I haven't done Lucy
I did a couple of voiceover things but
they were mostly for videos like
thanking the first responders and that
sort of thing but no proper cartoons yet
there's a new Joker there they have this
series Harley Quinn and it's there's the
whole cast has been rebooted because my
Batman is Kevin Conroy mm-hmm Kevin's
not doing it we're like at this point
we're like Laurel and Hardy right right
and they asked you want to do the Joker
I say is Kevin in it if they say yes I
say yes yeah yeah have you checked out
that new show do you like it I haven't
seen it yet I've seen clips and it looks
really good I you know I my only problem
is that it looks though appears and the
characters it would really appeal to
young children but they're apparently
dropping f-bombs and yeah it's
definitely x-rated and for adults oh I
know that if I were eight years old I'd
be really mad my parents wouldn't let me
watch it yeah I think they like make fun
of like the Snyder cut stuff and the
people that don't like the last Jedi and
all that stuff and they dress right oh
yeah I'll have to check it out like I
say I've seen clips and you know I
worked with Kaylee on on one episode of
the Big Bang and she's adorable so I'll
have to check it out
I can see by the look on your face you
weren't - expecting to see me again you
can see by the look on my face I'm gonna
clue who you are well you are guest
starring in one of the best comedies
that's out right now what we do in the
shadows and I I mean how did you get
involved in the first place were you a
big fan of the show how do how did this
come together I was a mad fan of the
film and when I heard they were new
television series I thought well
Jermaine and tyka are involved but
behind the scenes so I sort of lowered
my expectations I thought well there's
no way can be as good as the feature
film and I saw that first episode I was
just blown away you know it expands on
the idea there's all new characters the
the concept of an energy vampire that
I'd never heard before yeah we've all
met energy vampires in our lives so it
has a ring of truth to it but I was
tweeting about it to try and you know
tell my followers I love the show you
should watch this show mostly from a
selfish standpoint because everything I
like seems to get cancelled I'm still
mad they canceled the kids are alright
that was my favorite show last season
you know having grown up in a large
family you know with a Roman Catholic
father it's it seems so real to me so I
was really upset and with with shadows I
was trying to hopefully get people to
watch it it wasn't like I was trying to
offer myself to be on the show I'm happy
to be just in the audience well and then
they would they come preach out to you
and they're like hey come on in yeah
they did and when they send me the
script I thought for sure you know I'm
gonna be like the head of the PTA or I'm
gonna be working at the Department of
Motor Vehicles I saw that they were
wanting me to play the character called
the vampire I I just couldn't believe it
I thought oh my gosh I love a challenge
I've got to do this I loved you know
when you see that first look because I
you know so many people are so used to
seeing you as Luke Skywalker and then
you've got this like
white hair and got this totally
different look well it was it like kind
of putting that putting that look on
well it's very collaborative I mean we
had discussions about the Wardrobe was
pretty much their decision they you know
the sort of old-school European robes
and whatnot but with hair I thought I'm
going to be doing assault of my
billables he
so I was thinking slicked back dark hair
and the hair person showed me that
blonde wig but we tried it both ways and
the director came in and looked and she
goes look I want you to be happy you
decide and it took me a while but I
realized the when am I gonna have long
flowing white hair like never maybe soon
don't rush me Mary Lou doesn't cut it
but yeah yeah exactly
but no I was as it turns out I think the
hairdresser was right
she was really favoring the long flowing
white box and that's what we went with
I love it now who was on who was on set
when you were there we're Jemaine and
tyka there
Jermaine was and he was there the first
night Tycho was obviously busy with
other things but that first scene I
don't know whether you've seen it yet
but my story mostly involves my
character and Laszlo played by Matt
berry oh but when I arrived at the house
the entire cast was there Nadia and NAND
or and Guillermo and Colin Robinson and
Matt so it was great that I had at least
one scene with the whole cast cuz I like
I say I'm just such a fan and they're
all so good just one of the best
ensembles and I didn't have a lot to do
with with main cast other than that like
I say I don't want to give too much away
right well considering you are such a
fan I'm curious your thoughts about tyka
is now directing a Star Wars movie that
like I think last week I saw that when
franchises collide huh right well I'd
love to work with him but unfortunately
my my Star Wars days are over but like I
say there's so many stories they can
tell so many talented actors and writers
and directors that now I can be just a
fan and I am a fan so I'll always be
partial to to any Star Wars project yeah
yeah have you um it's time in the
audience this time can the audience I
mean it has that been like exciting for
you like have you been checking out
things like the Mandalorian what are you
benching from home yeah my son said dad
you gotta watch Mandalorian and again I
thought this is so smart to make a
minimalist where you can focus on the
characters in the story and the
advantage they have is they don't have
to deliver a epic special-effects
extravaganza they can really hone in on
the smaller stories and I thought it's
very much in the spirit of what George
wanted originally and I just thought it
was superb it was so well done have you
heard the rumor that Boba Fett might be
in the new season therefore having
survived the Sarlacc pit no I thought it
was I thought he was decades into being
digested at this point but I mean I
takes place I guess after Jedi and
before the sequel so yeah you know like
I say there's so many ways they can go
but those two Jon Favreau and Dave
Filoni I worked with they're both just
the right person in the right job
because they know they know it better
than I do
because that that's they're there you
know I'm one of these people were you
know I don't go back and watch the old
films and fans will come up to me and
ask me these questions and I have no
idea what they're talking about
I can't I can't imagine I think about
that with all the actors all the time
like especially Harrison being like I
don't you can get away with that cuz
period that era
to be here Reverend yeah supposed to be
more sincere and they'll ask some really
good questions they'll say something
like one person said to me why does an
r2d2 with these memory banks just tell
Luke that Darth Vader is his father and
I thought I have no idea that's a good
question because he would know but it
wouldn't be as dramatic if he went
people and I said what it was much
better well you know it's such a crazy
time right now I know people are feeling
anxious and you've been one of those
kind of positive voices on the Twitter's
that I've been following how do you keep
this positive attitude right now no you
know you've got to I mean you can't get
into despair you it's the old fighting
spirit you know what nothing can defeat
us
and we're all in this together as the
hashtag reads and I really believe that
I think Americans are and and people
around the world are they have to face
the challenge because there's no
alternative
[Music]
now you take you have what we do in the
shadows under your belt now do you have
like a dream guest starring role of
shows or movies that are out right now
is there anything that you really gee
you know what into the universe I you
know I don't really think that way I
mean I'm like I say I mean I was
surprised that even Star Wars came back
because I thought even if it comes back
it's not gonna involve our characters
will be all new characters I'm happy
just to see what comes along I mean what
we do in the shadows was unexpected but
it's not like I have a bucket list of oh
I want to play Hamlet and I want to mean
the movie version of Hamilton yeah
and that's just not the way I think I
mean but it's always a pleasant surprise
when people want to want you to come out
and do something well you're one of the
best so if you want you probably got it
Jax
[Music]